des dizaines de milliers de petites
entreprises se sont précipités pour
profiter du programme de prêts d'urgence
mis sur pied par ottawa
c'était la première journée hier pour
s'inscrire et 69 mille pme l'ont fait
par l'entremise des banques
ottawa offre des prêts sans intérêt
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2022 pouvant aller
jusqu'à 40 mille dollars
et puis de lundi à jeudi plus de 3
millions de canadiens ont fait une
demande pour la prestation canadienne
d'urgence depuis le 15 mars 5 millions
cinq cent soixante deux mille personnes
ont fait une demande pour cette
prestation ou pour l'assurance emploi
avec le roi jean yves duclos président
du conseil du trésor bonsoir monsieur
duclos monsieur du cloud est ce que vous
m'entendez alors maintenant je m'entends
très bien monsieur fillon soir à tout le
monde qui vous écoute
bonsoir on a l'impression que la machine
est fort mais tu sais qu'a tenu le coup
cette semaine est ce que c'est au delà
de vos espérances
mais on ne travaillait très fort et
l'auront là ce sont les fonctionnaires
de la fonction publique des services
canada et de l'agent de revenus qui
n'ont jamais eu à relever un défi aussi
important on est très fiers et très
reconnaissant pour leur travail parce
que comme on l'avait dit ce sont des
millions de canadiens qui autrement
n'auraient pas eu l'aide d'urgence dont
ils ont absolument besoin en ces temps
difficiles
est il normal que des gens aient reçu
deux paiements de prestations
canadiennes d'urgence ou des paiements
d'assurance emploi et des paiements de
prestations d'urgence donc rappelons
l'objectif le plus important c'était de
livrer rapidement et efficacement des
prestations à près de 5,6 millions si on
exclut ceux qui ont appliqué depuis le
15 mars
famille et canadiens qui n'auraient pas
eu autrement rien pour mettre du pain
sur la table dont il ya eu évidemment
comme on s'y attendait des problèmes la
confusion des gens qui ont fait une
demande deux fois et s'est de suite ce
qui est important c'est que pour tous
ceux qui ont reçu de l'aide c'est 2000 $
par mois deux mille dollars par mois ci
plus que deux villes de la par mois et
que vous pensez avoir droit d'avoir plus
que ça avait budgété 2000 $ par mois
si vous avez un doute ou mettez le
montant excédentaire de côté parce que
l'agent de revenu du canada va bientôt
procéder à des vérifications il se
pourrait que des gens aient besoin de
rembourser l'excédent mais ce qu'il y a
eu des erreurs dans la transmission dans
les versements mais probablement que oui
parce que des gens qui ont malgré tout
ce qu'on avait dit là qu'ils ont fait à
la fois une demande d'assurance emploi à
partir du 15 mars
et on leur avait il ne fait pas un autre
demande de prestations d'urgence parce
que notre prestation d'assurance emploi
va automatiquement devenir une
prestation d'urgence n'est près sûr que
personne soit laissé pour compte
la machine a accepté toutes les demandes
pour l'instant donc des gens qui ont
probablement reçu plus que le 2000 $
auxquels ils ont droit pour le premier
mois
alors c'est à ces gens là que je dis
soyez plus d'un ces deux mille dollars
par mois si vous pensez avoir reçu trop
vous le mettez de côté pour devoir
rembourser mensuellement les
travailleurs saisonniers
auront-ils l'aide du gouvernement mais
on comprend l'enjeu des travailleurs
saisonniers
ce sont des travailleurs qui travaillent
très fort dans des conditions souvent
manuel difficile avec des salaires qui
sont modestes des gens aussi qui font
vivre leurs communautés partout dans au
canada mais je partais line richer par
exemple des pêcheurs des gens en
foresterie déjà dans le tourisme a aussi
qui ont des emplois 16 nice et pas des
travailleurs s'est dit ce sont des gens
qui ont un travail saisonnier et qui
font vivre leurs communautés alors on
comprend très bien leur situation
monsieur trudeau déjà clairement indiqué
contre la rfa là dessus et les
discussions et les travaux continuent
donc est ce qu'ils vont voir l'aide du
gouvernement
alors l'engagement est clair c'est qu'on
veut en faire en sorte que ce grand
filet social qu'on est mis en place qui
couvre très large et l'émail les plus
petites possibles et les mailles des
plus petites possibles c pour attraper
ces travailleurs saisonniers qui
autrement seraient sans aucune aide au
cours des prochaines semaines et des
prochains mois donc il y aura une
annonce dans les prochains jours donc je
vous dis c'est qu'il y aura il ya
présentement du travail sérieux qui se
fait suite à l'engagement et à la 3
monsieur triaud plus tôt cette semaine
et on espère avoir des choses à dire
prochainement
faut-il en faire plus encore est ce que
d'autres programmes sont en train d'être
développés et la réponse est oui on
comprend tous le sentiment d'urgence
évidemment sanitaire mais le soma
sentiment d'urgence économique qui est
majeur il ya des millions de familles
des millions de travailleurs qui vivent
dans l'anxiété dans la sécurité
le gouvernement canadien voit la vitesse
grand v mais malgré ça j'ai encore
beaucoup de choses qui vont continuer de
devoir évoluer au cours des prochaines
semaines et des prochains mois préparez
vous une aide pour le secteur du pétrole
non le train est en trois morceaux
la première le premier morceau c'est
pour faire atterrir l'avion économique
je dirai qui tu es pris dans une grosse
tempête faire atterrir l'avion ils sont
tous ses passagers un tas donc la
prestation canadienne d'urgence est là
pour ça c'est le 2002 la par mois
l'autre étape c'est de sécuriser l'avion
une fois qu'ils sont la piste
d'atterrissage
et ça ça veut dire sécuriser le moteur
économique les pme et parlait tout à
l'heure d'hiver est urgent de 40000
dollars
mais on travaille aussi pour sécuriser
la callas la carcasse de l'avion les
ailes qui sont le moteur et la chaîne
d'approvisionnement de l'économie
canadienne donc effectivement d'autres
discussions qui se font pour protéger
certaines instructions structurel ou
d'importance nationale comme le pétrole
donc est ce que vous préparez une aide
pour le secteur pétrolier mais il ya
beaucoup d'industries structurellement
majeur au canada dit effectivement les
ressources naturelles
il ya aussi le transport et le tourisme
secteur culturel elle a beaucoup
d'autres que je réponds que vous
énumérez parce qu'on n'a pas le temps
mais on pense ici à sécuriser le tissu
économique du pays pour que caen va
venir le temps de faire re décoller
notre avion il y ait un moteur un avion
d elle en mettant de l'essence dans le
moteur on puisse faire décoller
rapidement on comprendre l'image là mais
mais pour le secteur pétrolier mais ce
qui est né à 10 20 milliards ne besoin
de 20 milliards pour la lgv est de
l'alberta est ce que vous travailler là
dessus
ce que je vous dis mais suffisant c'est
une très bonne question c'est qu'on
travaille pour solidifier le tissu
économique
du pays le secteur des ressources
naturelles est un facteur majeur
évidemment comme beaucoup d'autres
secteurs donc on est tous conscients
qu'il faut travailler très fort de
manière évidemment adapté à chacun des
secteurs est toujours été mon objectif
c'est qu'on en sort plus fort lorsque
viendra le temps de relancer l'économie
depuis le début de tout ce qui s'est
passé là il ya eu tuteur de programmer
la subvention salariale sera discutée
demain au parlement il ya la prestation
d'urgence ya beaucoup de choses que vous
avez fait
mais en a qui disent pourquoi pas donné
2000 $ à tout le monde ou avoir un
revenu universel un revenu de base est
ce qu'on devrait pas avoir un mécanisme
plus un d'urgence bon deux réponses
rapides la première c'est que on est
allé rapidement pour objectif principal
de sécuriser les conditions très
difficiles de ce qu'ils perdaient tout
de la récession canadienne d'urgence et
pour ceux qui ont tout perdu qui ont
aidé 0 $ pour payer les factures
ça c'était la première étape mais on se
rend très bien compte que notre système
de filet social qui a été bâti à la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale n'est pas
adapté à l'urgence que l'on vit
maintenant on savait que ce système là
n'était pas non plus adapté pour
beaucoup d'autres travailleurs avant
l'urgence les travailleurs autonomes
ceux qui font des emplois à temps
partiel donc le système qui repose
largement au fédéral sur le système
d'assurance emploi
on savait n'était pas adapté
correctement pour des conditions
normales ce qu'on découvre maintenant
c'est qu'il n'est pas adapté
certainement pour des conditions
d'urgence comme celle qu'on vit et il ya
beaucoup de leçons qu'on est en train
d'apprendre qu'ils vont nous servir pour
la suite
ouais ça serait intéressant ce serait
intéressant d'en parler on est encore au
coeur de la crise mais de voir la suite
lorsqu'on va faire après ça au cas où ça
nous arrive encore malheureusement
merci beaucoup monsieur duclos merci de
ces firmes en soirée bonne soirée